hi good to see everybody I'm very
excited to be here it's my first strange
loop and so far it's been absolutely
amazing so I hope I can continue the
trend and give you also a good lecture a
tiny morning I guess this disclaimer
usually when I you know talk about
right-to-left in lectures there's a side
effect where people's brains start
leaking out of their ears at some point
so in order to mitigate that a little
bit I added a couple of cute animal
pictures so bear with me and hopefully
we'll get through this so welcome to
wait it does what a supporting right to
left can expose your bad UX decisions so
a little bit about me and why am I even
talking about this
my name is Morial shot lander I work at
the Wikimedia Foundation at the global
collaboration team and I am an avid
enthusiast for right-to-left support I
also think in right-to-left I speak
Hebrew and I'm an occasional answering
Stack Overflow and the reason that I
mentioned this is that a lot of the
inspirations for this talk came from
there there's a lot of questions that I
keep see popping up that are really
interesting good questions but really I
kind of like exposing probably problems
with the UX in general and not
necessarily just with right-to-left
support and then that gave kind of like
birth to the idea of this this lecture
and also because a unicode last year
started adding emoji into unicode I am
also oops and emoji now right a little
bit of the hair is missing but all right
so what's over a little bit of an
introduction to languages and Wikipedia
in general so Wikipedia if you don't
know is a pretty large website we are
the fifth largest according to Alexa in
the global reach um just pretty cool
what you might not be aware of is that
we support 285 content Wikipedia's so
just like we have English Wikipedia we
also have Hebrew in Spanish and to 195
more please don't make me go over the
and the each Wikipedia is a unique
community so we don't have one website
and then it's being translated endlessly
and that's it
each Wikipedia each community has its
own way of writing things its own rules
and while people do tend to kind of like
you know translate from a lot of times
from English or from other big wiki's
it's not a must it's not an automatic
translation that every Wikipedia is the
same so 285 content languages but we
also support 424 interface languages and
I'm gonna touch about the difference
between content and interface in a
minute
but to those of you who are great with
math that gives us about 120,000
combinations of languages on the screen
at any given time depending on what the
user wants which is great and as you can
imagine it also raises a bunch of you
know issues and we need to really deal
with those and this is a pretty unique
problem so this is from 2014 but it
didn't change that much so Wikipedia is
all the way to the right with 285
languages and you can see that the next
up is Google with 145 it may have
changed a little but probably not
doubled and then we have Facebook with
53 we have Google Translate with ad we
support a lot of languages we also have
more than just Wikipedia we have other
projects that we're supporting we have
Wikimedia Commons that have images who
ever give voyage became news wikiquote I
always forget some of those when I talk
about them so I just put the image on
the screen each one of those or almost
each one of those also has almost 280
foreign languages so there's wiki
Wiktionary in English Spanish in Hebrew
etc etc so if if you keep track of all
of this we eventually have about 900
websites that we keep track of you know
not that many sure so with that said
let's go a little bit of introduction of
what is right to left I don't know if
you've all encountered this online or
how how deeply you've encountered so
that will go very briefly just what it
is and why is that such a challenge
so this is the sentence we all know the
quick brown fox jumps over the lazy dog
we will use that to check out into fonts
because it uses all of the alphabet
great when we read it from the left to
the right awesome well this is the
equivalent sentence in Hebrew it
literally says a little bunny ate a
little carrot that tasted like lettuce
and enough for some reason that
apparently includes all the letters in
the Hebrew alphabet
who knew but as you can see from my
hinting at aligning it to the right the
way that we read it is from the right to
the left okay so we have you know text
that we read from the left and text that
we read from the right why is that so
difficult well it's actually difficult
because it touches on more things than
just typing and writing it touches on
something called a mental model so if
you think about it really
here are two an example of two
Wikipedia's on the right is the hebrew
key pedia it's right to left aligned and
on the left is the English Wikipedia
it's left to right and you can see that
the logo is mirrored so on the Hebrew
key PJ's on the right on the English
Wikipedia it's on the left the menu is
also married English Wikipedia it's on
the left Hebrew it's on the right also
the tabs on the top
they're aligned right aligned right and
left great but really what what this
means is that beyond typing the
expectations of where things are
supposed to be is different the
definition of where things start where
things end are reversed so as a Hebrew
speaker as a right-to-left user my
definition of beginning is on the
right-hand side so I would expect to see
a logo on the right-hand side because my
eyes automatically go there which is why
the interface is flipped so this is the
you know main issue really with
developing right-to-left languages but
it would have been so much easier if
that's all we needed to do just you know
mirror everything sure if only so let's
see very briefly just about
right-to-left in Wikipedia so in
Wikipedia out of the 285 languages we
have 17 that are right-to-left
Wikipedia's but as I kind of hinted at
in the previous sentence
right to left is not exactly all right
to left we always have a little bit of
left to right in there and that is
actually true also for Wikipedia because
if you have an entry about someone not
that was not born in an english-speaking
country they will have the same kind of
thing except their name will be in the
other language right and if that is a
person from that whose name is Farsi or
Arabic or Hebrew that will be right to
left so we do have mixes of stuff and we
have to deal with it and all of this is
also user-generated content our users
create the content we don't do that so
how do we deal with that so this really
raises a bunch of issues that um that
are fun to deal with I think not many
agree with me but I think they're really
fun and yeah I'm gonna let you consider
that so dude why do you talk backwards
all the time backwards talking I am NOT
English centric view of grammar
structures you have so keep that in mind
I would say that you know English
speakers consider right-to-left
backwards we actually consider
left-to-right backwards but you know it
depends who you ask again so there's one
more introduction that I'm gonna do uh
this one is where your brain might start
leaking out of your ears so bear with me
so unicode is the system that we all
used to type vast majority of all
programs and those that don't use it
sick sick please use it Unicode
bi-directional algorithm is an algorithm
inside Unicode that dictates really what
to do when you have two directionality
is in a sentence or in a general text or
etc I highly recommend you read it sit
when you do you know with a cup of maybe
hot chocolate or something but um but I
highly recommend you read it it it looks
a lot more daunting than it actually is
and I'm gonna give you a couple of
resources maybe to help you out but
here's a very very quick introduction so
the bidirectional algorithm defines
three entity types strong weak and
neutral now this is an
oversimplification if anyone here deals
with a bi-directional algorithm I am
oversimplifying don't kill me I mean
it's just for the sake of
clarity a little bit so strong entities
actually affected the directionality of
all the entities around them weak ones
do not affect but there are affected by
the directionality that the strong ones
or the general context gave them and the
neutral ones that are just neutral they
don't do anything what does that mean
well in the strong one we have the
alphabet for the most part weak ones we
have punctuation and digits and neutral
space newline tab etc etc well as you
can see digit sits with a little star
next to it I'm gonna touch on that in a
second
but let's look at an example so here's a
sentence in Hebrew it's Albert Einstein
was born in blind in the middle there's
the English name or the German name
actually so when we look at it from the
bi-directional algorithm this is what
happens we have right-to-left and then
we have a sentence that is left to right
and then we have another sentence that
rewrites the left the bi-directional
algorithm knows that this is what's
going on because the alphabet is a
strong entity and the parentheses which
are weak entities just conform to their
context if you really want to cry you
can contact like um to me after the
lecture and I'll talk to you about
parentheses because there's a lot of
problems with those but for the most
part this is what happens and this is
useful for you know 99% of cases here's
a little bit of a weird example but that
does happen so here's here's a semi
sentence I guess basically what I have
here is the word Hebrew in Hebrew and
then the number 123 now notice that I'm
saying a hundred and twenty three and
not one two three because you remember
the little star over digits there is a
difference between separate digits and
compound numbers for the most part in
most right-to-left languages not all but
most right-to-left languages write
numbers that internally are left to
right so when I write a hundred and
twenty-three I actually write a hundred
and twenty-three from the left to the
right even though it's inside a
right-to-left sentence and yes it's when
you learn you know math in school
it can produce a lot of issues but this
is how it looks like okay so we have a
general sentence that is right-to-left
we said that numbers are weak so they
are being affected by you know the
alphabet well what would happen if I put
my cursor between the 1 and the 2 and
hits space that will happen all right
huh
okay well okay okay now I'm gonna take
my cursor and put it between the 2 and
the 3 and now hit space you probably
know where this is going and you'll be
right that's what happens well that
looked completely ridiculous
until you wait a minute and think about
it for for a second so the entire
context that I have here is
right-to-left right and what do I have
here well in the first instance I have
two words right to left a word and then
another word in the second instance I
have three words already I broke a word
apart and now one two three makes sense
and in the fourth I have four words one
word second words third word so the fact
that the initial instance the second
word is internally left-to-right doesn't
matter because once I broke that into
towards it's still right-to-left
all right so once you look at this
suddenly it makes sense even though it
looked really weird when you know you
didn't know what's going on and it's
okay because it looks really weird too
right the left users even though they
expect it so here's another example a
little bit more complex this time so I
have a sentence going English one two
three this time with spaces and then the
word Hebrew one two three and then
English now let's say that I'm taking
the word Hebrew that is italicized here
and I'm switching it with the actual
Hebrew word what do you think will
happen this will happen it's great right
it's awesome that makes no sense except
it dies let's break it apart a little
bit so here we have it English the word
in English for English is left to right
it's a strong right entity so it
dictated what the numbers are gonna do
so we have English one two three all
going left to right but then we break it
with Hebrew in Hebrew which is
right-to-left now the direction is right
to left and the number
following a week they follow that
direction from the right to the left as
expected and then we break it again with
the word English so when you color code
it it looks really good and very
understandable when you don't it looks
really weird
so granted usually we don't have that
kind of a sentence but we kind of can so
if you deal with you know English Hebrew
dates in between things can look really
weird and horrible and we also have
another thing called the general context
so if you are dealing with the web or
with general interfaces and you have an
input that has a context Direction
left-to-right or right-to-left the
general context of that input also
affects things so for example look at
the little period at the end here that
dot that period doesn't really know yet
where it's supposed to be its function
as far as its concerned the general
context is the context of the input
which means that from the LT arts and on
the right that's the end of the sentence
but if the direction is right to left as
far as its concerned at the end of the
sentence is towards the left now if I
continued that sentence after the period
in English then that periods context
would have changed to be left to right
and then it would revert back to being
on the road correct side while I type
it's great when things move for you when
you don't expect them but this is going
to be important for some of the examples
that we're going to look at so I told
you that you should read the
bi-directional algorithm I created a
little bit of introduction to it on my
website and because it's um mind-bending
and has a lot of examples for you to try
and like play around with I added a lot
of animated gifs to help you along so
feel free I think that these also will
be shared online but feel free to go and
break your brain with more fascinating
examples of what happens to
right-to-left so you might be saying
what my product doesn't really need
internationalization or people might be
saying that I really hope that people in
this conference did not say that because
everybody needs internationalization
here in Strangelove we see it we need
globalization and diversity and
inclusiveness not to mention it brings
you a bigger market
but and this is the point of this
lecture it also gets you a better code
it makes it generic it makes it
extendable it's easier to manage it see
just to think about and it results with
a better product so really planning for
right-to-left support itself makes your
product a lot better and it's really
easier to expose bad UX decisions by
just thinking about or trying to support
things with right-to-left so what does
that mean well let's go into some
examples so here's examples about how to
name your product actions or even your
code actions and I see this quite a lot
so here a couple of like examples that I
often see in you know software and so
you have you know arrows left and right
you have popups like where do the I'll
on align to to the left edge of the
button or the right edge of the button
on the middle or whatever now you have a
pop-up and then the pop-up has a little
indicator on top of it do I put the
indicator on the Left I put it on the
right do I put it you know where it is
and you see that a lot in many libraries
left right go that though that well when
you switch it to right-to-left it's
really confusing wait is it left left or
is it left but now when it's
right-to-left it's actually right and
when I go to the left do I go left words
or back or forward it can be super
confusing but you know what it's also
not really what you should call things
because that's not what they do that's
what they look like you should consider
calling things what they actually do so
the errors are not really left and right
their previous and next or before after
beginning and backwards and forwards and
that also has the benefit of being true
for both right right-to-left and
left-to-right
right pop-ups if you align it towards
the edge well aligned edge before or the
start of the edge or the element or the
beginning of the element etc etc instead
of saying left same with pop-ups
backwards start beginning and think
about things this way which will make
your code and your product a lot more
understandable in general and allow you
to support right-to-left so in a
comedian foundation I don't know if you
can see this actually this was we have a
widget library and we have also pop-ups
will our pop-ups also
in the configuration you can choose the
position above below before and after so
we don't do left and right and then the
alignment which is the indicator
forwards backwards Center and then you
do have a force left and a force right
if you know that what you want is
actually force left regarded of
directionality and this allows anyone
that uses our stack including users that
create plugins that create user scripts
whatever to really know to support right
to left immediately without even
thinking about it so they don't even
need to do anything we just do it for
them here's another example for toolbars
so this is the toolbar in left to right
and right to left well we can see here's
a link it's flipped
here's the bullet list it's flipped we
actually are arguing about whether or
not it should be flipped but that's a
different issue and here's the wait a
minute hmm that's supposed to be flipped
no well is it let's think about this for
a minute let's think about it all right
so this is undo and redo and I want my
undo to be first in my redo to be second
dwell in left to right what does it mean
to undo I go backwards backwards it's
towards the left alright that works well
what does it mean to redo redo is
forward it stores the right well that
works okay I have undo and redo well
what is it in right-to-left well when
you're undoing right-to-left you go
backwards towards the right and when you
redo you go towards the left so really
what happened here is that you
absolutely flipped it twice so as you
can see things are not always as
straightforward as you would think and
here's another example of something done
a little bit them differently so this is
libera offers and this is the bullet
toolbar and this is in left-right and
then if you switch your direction to
right-to-left this is what happens it's
just mirrored and the developers you
know just mirrored everything which
seems to be great except this part here
which is not really helpful not really
working and when I did this
at the foundation I was told you should
show how we do it so here's how we do it
this is left to right and right to left
and as you can see we have our own
right-to-left icon and it actually makes
sense so I will also show you how you
can do that fairly easily without much
coding around it so that it switches for
you without blindly
you know switching everything so when it
comes to interface encode actions think
about your action what they actually
mean don't go by the literal action go
by its purpose did you really mean to go
left or did you mean to go to the
beginning or go backwards right consider
the real meaning of your icons do you
need to flip them do you not what do
they do is this like an interface action
is this an user action what does it do
and if you already flip them please flip
them properly so thinking about these
things can really clarify the UI for
your users it's not just for a
right-to-left support of course you
should be supporting right-to-left and I
will keep saying that but it's not just
for that it will clarify the UI it will
clarify it also the work for the coders
for the developers for everybody
alright here's another example numbers
and non numbers so let's say your
application is asking for a phone number
this is what it looks like in left right
and this is what it looks like in
right-to-left as we said for the most
part languages numbers are rendered
left-to-right so you know other than
alignment it looks so pretty okay right
sure except what happens if you want to
add you know international number like
+1 or whatever it is that's how it looks
like in a right-to-left the line input
why because the plus is a weak entity
and the entire input is right to left so
it thinks oh I'm weak I'm impacted by my
own context I'm staying to the right and
numbers are so weak so they don't affect
the direction at all so the plus stays
on the right that is very confusing and
can create a lot of issues now remember
that sometimes you don't even control
that some operating systems will that
just turn that into input for you to
write the left or to the direction
your operating system so in these cases
my recommendation is to force like if
you know that you have numbers and the
numbers are Latin and you know that you
need a phone number or whatever it is
then you know that it's left to right
and then force it left to right or find
another solution to represent
internationalization but be aware that
these things happen and as they happen
these things also happen now remember I
told you that weak entities you know
listen to the general context and we saw
that the incident of the period well
period is not the only weak entity
here's what happens this is my username
on on Wikipedia this is what happens
when I log in to the Hebrew key pedia
huh now to be fair and I'm gonna have to
say that because this video is gonna be
online and people who work very hard on
the bi-directional algorithm is probably
gonna see it this actually has been
fixed in the bidirectional algorithm the
problem is that browsers not all of them
have implemented that fix so as far as
we're concerned it's not yet fixed so
here's what happens the other way let's
say I created my username in Hebrew and
now I'm using it in you know English
Wikipedia or whatever the same thing
happens on the top there so really watch
out for misleading characters read the
Unicode bi-directional algorithm watch
out from parentheses plus minus comma
periods all those kind of things that we
think are so awesome and then can break
our stuff and be aware where the OS or
the environment can change context for
you there are a couple of apps native
Android or iOS apps that had problems
having people register because of those
things so let's talk about interface
business contact so here's a quick
example this is again LibreOffice and I
installed it twice once in English and
once in Hebrew so I don't know if you
can see that a little bit but the
interface itself even though the content
I wrote like in Hebrew English at the
top the interface is English you have
the tabs normal outline notes etc
etcetera are all aligned from the left
even though I wrote in the slide in
Hebrew and then on the bottom you have
the same thing except it's aligned to
the right it's a right-to-left interface
I installed it in Hebrew
and all the tabs are just right the line
written in Hebrew even though in the
middle I wrote in English so this is a
concept that is known for applications
right the separation between content and
interface and in Wikipedia we also do
that so let's say I work on the Spanish
Wikipedia and I want to help out and I
want to you know work but you know what
my Spanish is good but it's not good
enough to really remember the technical
terms of the you know settings and stuff
like that so what I can do is I can work
in the Spanish Wikipedia but I can
switch my interface language to English
so all the content remain the same it
still the Spanish Wikipedia but my
sidebar and the top bar and everything
and all the all the notifications that
I'm getting all the notices is all now
English so it's easier for me to work
that's great but what happens if I want
to do the same thing with right-to-left
and left-to-right and I can you can
imagine where this is going so this is
the Hebrew Wikipedia and this is the
Hebrew key pedia with English interface
you can already see that things are
flipping but not entirely so this is the
content the content remained the same
we're still in the Hebrew Wikipedia but
all of the interface flipped just like
we saw with between the two wiki's right
English in Hebrew okay here's another
kind of like you know dig digging deeper
into the interface this is both of those
are from here where Wikipedia the right
one is just regular RTL little phrase
the left one is when I look at it with
an English interface so this flipped
okay that makes sense you know from the
right from the left that's great this
one happens when I start searching
though so okay I get a little drop-down
with you know recommendations for my
search but actually does it need to
switch I mean if I'm searching the
Hebrew QPD I'm probably searching in
Hebrew so is that interface there's a
content I don't know we're arguing about
that but the point is it's not always as
clear so you need to really think about
your products pieces properly you need
to consider is content is it interface
if it is content isolated from the
interface as much as you can
and then are your actions content
dependent
or the interface driven these are things
that are really useful to consider
regardless of supporting right-to-left
but even more so when your support
right-to-left and languages in general
this is a small example I just thought
it was a little funny so this is me
inviting my friend groaned to join some
group whose name is an inn brew maximum
two terms this is on the web so this is
the dafuk Asian on the web and here's
the notification on mobile so now the
Hebrew has no spaces in there and it's
backwards terms to maximum this is both
Facebook be consistent please I mean we
already have right-to-left issues if
you're already doing your own thing
please be consistent and using
right-to-left can help you figure out
where you're not consistent also some
[Music]
systems try to guess what your what you
mean so Facebook and Google if you start
typing they will count the number of
words in either language and then figure
out if they need to align it to the
right or align it to the left each one
of them does it differently by the way
which is great for users never know what
you're gonna get but it's inconsistent
between web and mobile which basically
means it's useless because as you type
you say oh it's gonna you know turn for
me but no wait does it know so if you do
that if you decide to guess please be
consistent so here's another example
about user-generated content so this is
from Wikipedia as well we have a system
for notifications if you participate in
them you know discussion board you can
get to notice saying oh there's a new
topic rated but discussion boards the
board name and the board and the topic
names are all user-generated so there's
nothing preventing someone from coming
in and creating a name for either the
board or the topic in Hebrew for example
or Arabic right so this is what it looks
like in English so you have you know new
topic created on discussion board one
new topic
- all right this is what happens when
both the board and the topic are in
Hebrew
they're flipped now so really what it
says is needed stop discussion topic
created on the topic and here's the
discussion board name so it's all
flipped and if you'll look at this I
know it's confusing but if you think
about this for a minute I really what I
have here is one big string that is
alright to lift and inside it there's
just punctuation right : and quotes so
obviously the by correctional algorithm
says oh it's all Hebrew OOP not helpful
but there is a solution for that we can
use something called isolation so we
know that board name and topic title are
two things we cannot control and we
don't know what is going to be in there
either directionality or fonts whatever
it is so we can already say isolate
those two things just make sure that
they are outside of the general break
you know whatever bi-directional rules
you have these two are isolated from
that and actually and this isolation is
part of the algorithm the algorithm
allows for it of course and when you do
that now it actually is correct so you
have new topic created on the board and
here's the topic title here's another
example this is what happens with Gmail
when you have a flight so this is you
know you have your legs and it notifies
you you know with your leg to and from
and everything and this is a jimmy'll in
Hebrew so you have a tel-aviv
to Istanbul alright well if it was in
English it would have said tel-aviv to
Istanbul 28 May 8 40 in Hebrew though we
seem to have a little bit of a problem
here the 28 is not really with the date
where it should be and you can probably
guess why already right the 28 is a
number follows you know the alphabet
great but not so great but we can
isolate this we already know if we are
the ones who are building this and you
know you already know that you might not
control the interface but you know that
the TLV and ICT and all of those are
always in english and even if they're
not probably are most of the time so
just isolate them and if you isolate
them they work and then you can have
your interface separate from your Khan
so user generated content is really good
idea to always isolate that you never
know what the user types the user keep
surprising you beware of things like
comments user name tagline things that
you wouldn't consider you know oh that's
not kosta yes it is and the users will
sometimes try and succeed in inserting
really weird stuff in there and if you
try to validate so if you try to say oh
this is clearly you know Hebrew this is
clearly Arabic and not so much because
sometimes you have things like numbers
parentheses you have stopped their stuff
and not very helpful so be very very
careful and you don't always control we
come back to that so don't always
control the interface direction so and
the you know the example that we saw
with Gmail I mean they generally control
because they programmed the fact that
you can make it right to left but if you
would have looked and I had a couple of
examples if you find I can show you
later of emails that companies sent to
other people and then how they look like
in a right-to-left Gmail it's rendered
completely backwards right so you don't
always control where the user is viewing
whatever you send them so take that into
account and try to make sure that things
are what you want to to do an isolate
stuff so now that I broke your brain and
made everybody very sad about the state
of things I will now go into helpful
tools because we do have them so here's
what we are using a new key media
foundation and I told you about the the
icon that is flipping instead of like
menu automatically flipping it we have a
library called CSS Janus it has actually
started as a Google project but then
stopped being maintained and we picked
it up it's available as an NPM module
module and the PHP library and what it
does really is
oops it takes CSS rules like this one
for example content float
dah-dah-dah and flips them for you and
you can tell it you know what flip
everything except this rule and then it
won't flip that rule so it's very very
useful it also works on images which is
how we do you know the the flipping of
the bullets that you saw or the numbered
list we don't have to like you know make
a system to mirror everything and then
go oh no what did we do with mirroring
we have icons for left icon for right
and we have this system which is super
super useful
it's absolutely open-source feel free to
use it and contribute to it we also have
a thing called translate wiki so this is
more general and it does touch on
right-to-left but it also touches on
everything and I highly recommend that
this system is open-source it's free and
you can use it in your own projects
if you conform to kind of like you know
the structure that it expects what it
does is that if you do use it in your
own project it allows people to
translate with contexts so this is what
it looks like if you want to translate
you have the original you know a string
for hide minor edits from recent changes
and then you have the translation that
the user can insert but over the
right-hand side you also have an
explanation context like where is this
going to be what is it talking about and
as you can see from this message
supports the use of gender whether or
not you need to gentrify
you know things which happen a lot in
languages outside of English speaking of
which it also allows you a very robust
fairly robust way to translate stuff
like using gender using plural very
complex plural and then mixing the two
together however you want so highly
recommend that translate wiki go check
it out this is also the way that we
translate out of all of media wiki and
all of our wikimedia stack if you want
to help translate please feel free we
would always love to do have more more
eyes on that and this is my website RTL
WTF when the new TLDs came out i was
like of course I'm getting that one
there's also an LTR WTF is the same
website except one of them is a line
right and one of them is aligned left so
feel free to go in there there's a
couple of my lectures in there and
there's a couple of explanations the
history and experimentations with
right-to-left craziness
selecting stuff selecting with your
mouse versus selecting with your
keyboard it's great it's also for
consistent not so um the samurais beware
of mixed content inputs if you have
mixed contents you need to really watch
out maybe split them apart
think about where elements are placed
through your interface to go to the
right there's go to the left you need it
in the beginning of something and
thinking about what things should look
like can help you clarify the UI as we
mentioned clearly separate content from
interface it's not that easy so spend
the time to think about which part is
what in your product and why does it
matter and what is the user expected or
expecting to see when they interact with
it please please be consistent across
platforms as it is right-to-left users
don't expect much online it's really
confusing when you know they learn the
behavior in one platform and then they
go to another platform completely
different make sure all user-generated
content is isolated and actually not
just user-generated content even things
that you know is going to be interface
versus things that you already know in
advance like in the Gmail example and
please support the internationalization
and please support right-to-left it's
super super important so I do know that
I have three minutes so I was going to
just finish here but I'm gonna give you
a little bonus a little bonus about the
emoticons yes and it starts with a cute
animal because your brain is going to
melt now so this is for the most part
emoticons go fairly you know
straightforward in left-to-right
right-to-left it goes the same way
except you need to tilt your head you
know the other way around so this is
smiley and this is sadly and all is good
in the world except for these
especially the bottom one where my mom
would send me you no messages hey how
are you doing and I would say I'm at the
office grin and she would call me
sterile why sobbing so if you have a
product that has these consider maybe
giving people the option for an emoji or
something now because this happens a lot
of right-to-left users instead of typing
: and then D will type D and then : so
if your system takes these things and
then figures out whether to you know
migrate them into emoji take that into
account because we are yes the situation
is very sabe apparently alright then
that's it for me thank you very much
[Applause]